yesterday this house engaged in the
first part of a bi-partisan
bipartisan effort it was bipartisan
yesterday but it is a bifurcated effort
as well bifurcated because yesterday
this house voted by with the vote of two
hundred and forty four to condemn the
president yesterday's vote was to
condemn first part of the bifurcated
process today's vote is to determine
whether or not we will punish the
president the effort yesterday was
wonderful I supported it but it does not
punish the president it does not find
him he will remain in office today we
will deal with the question of what his
punishment should be today between 4:00
and 5:00 o'clock somewhere in there
there will be articles of impeachment
voted on this will be the opportunity
for us to go on record letting the world
know where we stand if we both the table
we are voting not to invent advanced
impeachment if we vote to send it to the
Judiciary Committee we're voting not to
advance impeachment I will not vote a
table I will not go to send it to the
Judiciary Committee I will want to move
forward so that we can vote to impeach
this president has committed impeachable
offenses yesterday we condemned him for
them today is our opportunity to punish
him for them and for those who might say
well if you do this there may be some
people who won't like you well there are
times when you have to do that which is
neither safe nor politic nor popular you
have to do it because it's right but I
would also say this if we voted
yesterday to condemn him those who are
not going to like you are not going to
like you any more today when you vote to
impeach then they will if you vote not
to impeach they are still going to be
where they were when you decided that
you are not going to support what the
president has been doing since he's been
in office finally this mr. speaker
I love my country it means something to
me to be a part of the fiber and fabric
of this country and because I love it I
will not allow anyone to be above the
law the president has been above the law
some 91 days since the Muller report was
presented some 91 days I think that it's
time for us to send the president a
clear message that he is not above the
law
I think it is time for us to impeach I
also believe that this and understand
that what we're doing today with
impeachment does not impact the Muller
report it does not impact what the
Judiciary Committee is doing or any
other committee investigating
obstruction obstruction has nothing to
do with what we will vote on today this
is about what the president has done
you cannot incite people to harm other
people with your words you can't yell
fire in a crowded theater the president
has committed an impeachable offense and
we ought to take it up he ought to be
impeached I will vote to invent advance
to impeachment and I will pray that this
president will be impeached today I
yield back the balance of my time